[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off the record
where we talk about
whatever we want today
thanks so much for coming of course very
excited to be here
in the iconic uh studio yeah what do you
think of the studio
i mean it looks like [ __ ] yeah yes
honesty i love it
when he said he's like where's the
bathroom i was like oh no
he just pointed me to a corner i was
like i gotta pee in that corner all
right i thought he wouldn't have to go
while he's here
you know we haven't had the cleaners
here in like months no i know this
i know that no i love it it's very cool
it's very cool it doesn't show up on
camera though does it i know it looks
great on camera
no it's great they got the snacks been
there for years
absolutely yeah don't touch any of them
it's only the healthy ones
usually that that that thing is stacked
with a lot but our snack lady just
bounced on us a couple months ago yeah
it's because we called her a snack lady
yeah he never called her by her name
maybe yeah
it's an honor to be here thanks for
having me you know um i've had a text
conversation with you like
years ago dude uh like decades ago like
a decade yeah it was
it was years it was when we were still
doing jk films i remember
i remember that tim connected us
together i think
because we needed someone for a skit
and he was like oh yeah yeah my buddy
like randall you guys were doing wild
and out together or something
oh no i never did in wilding out with
tim oh really or maybe
did you know him at the time i don't
think
not 10 years ago with someone it might
have been you know what it might have
it might have been the wong fu guys or
or maybe really i thought it was two
could somebody could somebody send this
to tim and be like he doesn't know you
no i know it's him no i know it's him
i'm a fan
of tim well there was someone that
definitely text introduced us
yeah and then i had i have your number
and then um
we stopped filming skits like right
right after that conversation we went
and we focused on jk news and all showed
up on set i was like where the hell are
these dudes
they didn't tell me they stopped filming
skits yeah
no i remember i i remember i was trying
to remember if i
met you because i you know i got turned
on to you guys
early and i felt i felt like in my
memory i met you guys but i
don't i i guess it was just over email
or text
yeah i've had yeah i have i've had a
text conversation with you
and then i i i checked today if i still
had your number
if it's the same number that starts with
the eight
that's your number there's a lot of
numbers to start with eight in this area
that is my number that is right now he
lives in california that is the worst
flex i've ever seen
i'm not gonna tell them i'm not gonna
tell them what number it is they're
gonna call him the first number guess
the number
guess the number the first number starts
with an a it's with the eight
i was like oh i have a number he gets it
right i will answer you would be the
worst tv
you'd be the worst tv psychic of all
time
[Laughter]
no that's cool so then what did you
think when you first like
actually watched the skits or what was
your first introduction into
into jk yeah i mean i i watched i used
to watch the skits
like early on and and uh you wanted to
sign
actually
[Laughter]
throughout the years i just kind of you
know would check in and fall down rabbit
holes and just like oh my gosh
i feel like i know like you guys well
all your fans
know you guys because you you share so
much your your lives on
uh on your platform so uh so yeah it's
uh it's it's very cool to be here i feel
like i've seen you though before wilding
out somewhere
did you do wong fu stuff before wilding
out uh
i think i did wong fu stuff after
oh actually yeah i think i did wong fu
are you talking about a live show
i did a lot of live shows did you ever
do like a sketch
comedy or maybe improv troupe where
there was a couch
and then it was like a family of ninjas
what that was very specific
yeah family and names we used to
actually support the asian american
community but now we don't
do it we went to we went to all kinds of
comedy shows sketch shows improv shows
back in the day i remember that yeah i i
think i think oh wait a minute yeah yeah
yeah
the bit was it was a play yeah yes yes
it was called the achievers
do you remember is that what it's called
i don't know i was 13 i think i forgot
we weren't 13
dude we were like 20 i was 45 at the
time
yeah i think if it was a couch it was it
was a play called the achievers i think
yeah cause that could have been our
first time maybe that we saw that's
probably where
yeah and then like when i saw you on
wild or not i was like oh shoot
i've seen this guy and then you came out
on like wong fu and all that stuff and i
just
yeah it was kind of like oh that's crazy
that you guys are at that
i'm actually curious i want to ask what
got you into acting
uh when i was in college at ucla
i uh wanted to be a writer
and only because in my english class
that my teacher was like hey
you know you're pretty good you're a
good writer you should think of major in
in english and that was like validation
so i was like oh my god i'm gonna be a
writer i'm gonna be a writer you know
what kind of write like screenplays or
like well at the time it was at the time
like
uh um plays stage plays
were you an actor then like no not at
all zero acting
no drama class just writing shy kid
had no inkling to to uh get into uh
entertainment or anything and then and
then
through playwriting me and my friends
started this theater company at ucla
and our first show was a play that i
wrote like a full play
and uh you know we held auditions and
they were just a bunch of little small
parts in the
in the thing that we couldn't fill so we
were like let's just
you know the writer will play a part the
director will play a part you know
and uh and that was my first time on
stage just a little part in a play that
i wrote and i was like oh my gosh it's
so fun
you know yeah yeah and after that i i'll
you know did more plays and more plays
and that in that theater company and
eventually i was like
i would love to do this one day and was
it comedian your early stuff was that
comedic stuff yeah yeah it was all it
was all comedy yeah
yeah that's what we did in in college
and then does the theater company still
exist
yeah what is it called it's called lapu
the coyote that cares theater company
that's epic yeah and it's still it's
like
20 plus years wow yeah at ucla you ever
go back and visit
and like you know over the years i
haven't in a while
but uh over the years i check in and you
know and just see the kids and
yeah it's crazy they know that you
created it yeah yeah
not just me though it was two other guys
and and and a lot of people you know
working as actors and and writers and
producers came from that theater company
is that like a frat where you
like like create something and it just
keeps living on and you're like an
alumni but then like you don't control
it
grow out of it yeah yeah like everyone
or street gang or street gang
very similar all right yeah so yeah
allie wong came out of that group yeah
there's this production company i'm in i
i co-founded right now and two of my
partners came from that theater company
yeah so it's was it like more asian
specific or was it
oh okay yeah it was like and it was a
bunch of it was mostly like
non-theater majors on campus who people
doing like science and math majors but
who also wanted to perform
oh [ __ ] that's interesting so we got a
lot of parents mad with that theater
company
because a lot of them ended up wanting
to do it you know why didn't you guys
call it like
the science theater company so the
parents are like
oh i guess they're doing more stuff
right
math sciences the theater only a pluses
good student theater company yeah so
ended up pursuing acting i guess in part
because of those times but
but it wasn't a way later that i ended
up pursuing
after that are you like nose down i'm
i'm an actor i'm going hard
no no i i did not think it was like at
all possible so i was like i'm just
going to do it on the side for fun
the asian guilt took asian guilt yeah
that's my
mom and my dad's voice just telling me
like it's not going to work out so
are you studying that and you keep like
accomplishing things and you're like
well
it's this is an awesome side gig having
a
what 10 season shows just a good side
gig here
like whatever no you're on the show and
they're like it's gonna get canceled
i know that i definitely i'm always
thinking that
every season i would think that yeah i
mean it's just that
you know just kind of protecting myself
you ever go to like the producers like
hey can you talk to my mom instead
we're gonna do okay
[Laughter]
when you're talking about it are you uh
the show are you ever like
like yeah when we're doing fresh or do
you or are you like when we're you know
we're we're on boat
yeah you look it though you look very
cool thank you appreciate it appreciate
what was it that you were studying when
you were in ucla
i was studying um english with the
creative writings
so but it was more like short story
that's already a rebel major though
like if you tell any asian parent that
you're that you're majoring in english
they'll be like what kind of job can you
get with that yeah yeah exactly and i
was a minor in asian american studies
which
was even more like my parents what the
hell is that yeah if you become a major
in asian american studies
asian parents will resent you yeah but
they don't understand
i'll teach you this [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
yeah well then i did
a master's program in asian american
studies afterwards so my parents were
just like what the hell is going on yeah
what kind of job can you
get being an asian like what like what
did they want you to study
come on man doctor doctor
lawyer right but my my thought at the
time was i was going to become a
professor that was my thought
and like you know my parents were like
oh okay academia
academia he'll write books but you have
to teach at harvard though
right or ivy league right exactly
exactly you can't be at east la college
man
nope they're gonna be like nope right
but uh but midway through
the master's program i was like no i
don't no it's not for me i think i want
to
perform oh that's cool yeah but i still
didn't pursue it to a way later i just
kind of did it for fun and then
like 10 years later i was like you know
what i'm just gonna do it i'm just gonna
what was the deciding factor for you
like was there like a single moment
singular moment that was like i have to
do this and this is the moment i'm
jumping over
i kept getting laid off of these jobs
like and i got laid off and i think at
the same time i just broken up with the
long-term
out of a long-term relationship it all
just kind of fell apart one day
and i was like oh my gosh i have nothing
i might as well just like
give it a shot i have nothing to lose
now you know sounds like our success
story
sometimes rock bottom is the best place
to start right oh yeah
because you have no options like if you
have shitty jobs and you have nowhere to
go
it kind of forces you to go well i might
as well just try to be happy and do what
i want to do
exactly but but that's but it's a tough
thing to do when you're rock bottom
because when you're rock bottom you just
want to like
just mope you know yeah so i did some
moping but and then i was like i gotta
get up i gotta
dust myself off and just go for it when
i do like motivational speeches at
colleges and stuff
and people go like oh like i wanna be an
actor but my mom won't let me i'll be
like good don't be one just don't
because then i go like man i don't want
to motivate more asians because they're
gonna it's just competition man
[Laughter]
just stay down dude don't don't pursue
it like i
what i don't want to see you at the
audition especially if they look similar
to you they have someone hey
similar body type no he's all asians
females just all of them no just know
all of them i want to take all the roles
dude
you're the only token possible no but
that's good though you know i think i i
think like
if if these people can hear like no
don't do it
it's it's difficult you're gonna you
know you're gonna fail most likely
and they still do it that means they're
real passionate about it
stubbornness yeah yeah and i think you
got it
i mean you guys all know you gotta you
gotta like love it
you know to to keep doing it so i feel
like
um when people sometimes ask this
question they're more in love with the
lifestyle than they
are about the craft because like when i
hear your story right like you
surprisingly a lot of people that's they
just kind of fell upon
entertainment in a lot of ways like at
least when the people that i'm around
like they're kind of like well yeah i
never really wanted to be a star but
like they just needed me for this role
and then i
got in but then the people that are like
thirsty
for it and they just want the fame and
the lifestyle
so bad i usually see a lot of like um
train wrecks like they get like 5 000
followers and then they're just like
a celebrity all already they're in it
for the wrong reasons
yeah yeah yeah that's not good i mean
you gotta like
i mean a lot of people who are in it for
the wrong reasons
do great you know they do fine and
they're the most successful people on
earth
yes the most no but but i feel like i
don't know they have an emptiness in
them you know what i mean like
i don't know you know chasing something
that will never really come to fruition
and i'm not quite sure what that is
trying to fill a hole that
can't be filled by that stuff it needs
to be filled by warming drugs cocaine
yeah yeah yeah meaningful stuff and when
i see the train wreck i'm like yes
because you know you're making room for
one more
what was the uh like gig or project that
you
first landed that you're like okay cool
i think i can make a career out of this
and it's not still
the side big break i mean like
every early one i thought was a huge
deal even if it wasn't you know
the first thing i booked was this uh um
commercial for the asian channel it was
like all in mandarin
voice over and i got paid like 20
dollars
and like and it's very chinese
and i was like i made it i'm on tv
i'm a professional i'm gonna buy a car
you know
i know but then in retrospect it was
like oh man that was
just the stepping stone but i think
every time like uh
you know something bigger would be like
oh this is amazing i think when
when i did wild and out that was like a
big stepping stone because it was my
first time doing something
semi-regular you know like and it was
also
this hit show you know so uh so that was
pretty cool
and uh shout out nick cannon have you
had a naked moment
where you're like i [ __ ] made it now
and you go up to the mirror and like
suck it yeah [ __ ] it you [ __ ] haters
you ever yeah anybody suck it haters
[Laughter]
tell that to my wife every day i know
you hate her um no i
you know i don't i don't know i i i
don't think i've ever had that where i
mean i've i've had like situations where
i'd be working and
i just like remind myself to take this
in
and enjoy it and and you know cherish it
and
and don't take it for granted while you
tell the pa to go fetch something for
you
[Laughter]
yeah an oat milk latte
yeah extra said oat milk
i'm so grateful for this but i i mean
i've had a lot of those where just like
oh man i i gotta just remember this
don't take this for granted because this
is you know you know stuff like that
is it because maybe do you feel like in
the environment you tend to see people
maybe take it for granted
and you're just like a reminder to not
yeah i think so i think
yeah and you know it's it's all gonna
end you know like it's all gonna dry up
eventually
you know and that's just inevitable
that's just life so like
just instead of not being in the moment
you know just kind of like this this is
like so this is amazing to me i'm having
so much fun
i'm gonna remember this and not just
like get through it and then
forget it you know this is getting kind
of dry too
but yeah yeah yeah great now so
then i i guess in that point how have
you felt like your family
like dynamics have changed in terms of
like uh like hey
uncle randall
i got his business idea it's my birthday
i'm graduating korean barbecue
restaurant
korea korean barbecue and spaghetti
come on uh i mean the fan i mean it
hasn't changed much
it hasn't changed i mean well with my
parents it hasn't changed
you know with my family at home uh you
know my wife is an
actor as well and you know we have a kid
and we i don't we don't we don't
bring it home that much you know we
don't talk we talk about other things
you know every now and again we'll help
each other with auditions but it's not
like uh
the main thing in our house you know
yeah
yeah it's not a big hollywood family you
don't take me as the hollywood type
no i was expecting more of like a like a
man when when we got on fresh off the
boat like every single night we would
party
like rock stars and then like you know
we'll be doing lines of coke and [ __ ]
now you wish that you
wish that were the kids no the thing is
like i know a lot of
um like like people who are
more like on a clean-cut image side on
on the
screen and then behind the scenes i know
who they really are and i'm like
tell me the truth because it's funnier
right right right right i'm like you're
not this clean-cut family guy i've seen
you
[ __ ] strung out trying to eat your
own shoes yep
[Laughter]
i mean i think you know because i
started later and i think i started like
finding uh quote unquote more success
later so as in like like you're older
yeah older so like i mean i was probably
my mid 30s once
when i started to make a living so you
had your like
hollywood life in your 20s i mean i was
just like
i never did because but i think if i had
found success
in my 20s i might have had a little more
cocaine
you know just a little more you're
already responsible by the time you came
into the industry
exactly i mean it wasn't so i got
married that things started really kind
of really taking off for me you know so
like at
that point it's like your wife was your
good luck charm yeah and
a lot of ways yeah yeah you already
mature and knew yourself
yes exactly i knew that's it i knew
myself yeah i knew myself better than i
did when i was younger
and if i didn't then i'd be finding
myself amidst all of that
finding yourself in a pile of coke
am i i still don't know
[Laughter]
just coke guns uh yeah
yeah no uh so yeah so you know in that
sense it's it was probably a good thing
i found it
like later yeah it was great yeah we got
a lot out of this i mean we found out
you're a responsible cocaine user yeah
oh gosh you guys are going to edit this
in a way that like
it can't be filled by that stuff it
needs to be filled by
drugs cocaine yeah yeah more meaningful
stuff exactly
finding yourself in a pile of coke
am i just coke guns
uh yeah yeah hello guys thank you guys
so much for watching all of our videos
and i know it's been a million years in
the making but we finally got
just kidding news merch yup so make sure
you go down to the store below
and you can run around yeah you can get
a piece
of jk news and thank you guys for
supporting thank you
bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you